el ausentismo en las mesas electorales
se llevó el protagonismo durante la
jornada electoral en perú al
escepticismo y el hartazgo de los
electores se sumó el miedo contraer el
hobbit 19 las mesas electorales por lo
que muchos prefirieron pagar la multa
del gobierno antes de exponerse a la
enfermedad esto es que el gobierno
prometió que iban a vacunar a los
miembros genes mucha gente entre ellas
estaban mis hijas querían ser miembro de
mesa pero al final después de esa
promesa les quitaron entonces es el
problema que estamos pagando ahora a
pesar de que el grupo más vulnerable fue
convocado desde las 7 de la mañana a las
9 para votar entre los que estaban
embarazadas ancianos y personas
discapacitadas a las 9
apenas el 71% de las mesas estaban
habilitadas para el voto y no fue hasta
las dos de la tarde cuando consiguieron
poner en marcha el 99 1% de los colegios
para lo que hicieron falta muchos
voluntarios por lo que algunos
candidatos a la presidencia criticaron
la gestión de la oficina nacional de
procesos electorales
al inicio la peor gestión en mi vida a
la gente mayor la han hecho esperar dos
horas tres horas al sol no ha abierto
ninguna mesa el miedo a salir a la calle
para ejercer el derecho a voto durante
la primera ronda de los comicios aumentó
con las altas cifras de muertes y
contagios por el virus
sí tengo miedo como muchas personas
tenemos miedo
tengo que votar
el candidato que se haga finalmente con
la presidencia tendrá que enfrentarse a
la crisis sanitaria y otros problemas
como la gestión económica y la
desconfianza política que imperan perú